this video is sponsored by brilliant
start learning today with the link in
the description
among fast food chains starbucks is
unique in the way that it dominates
mainstream culture
not only in the language it's trained us
all to use
tall grande venti etc
but also in the scrutiny it receives
no other cup design can command such
controversy
no other change of store policy gets so
much media attention
and no other drink has taken on such a
life of its own
as the pumpkin spice latte
mocked stereotyped and yet still highly
adored
starbucks is known everywhere as the
coffee shop
almost in a league of its own but what
you might
not know is that viewed from a financial
perspective
starbucks is far more than a seller of
expensive drinks
starbucks has become a bank whether you
know it or not
starbucks might already be your bank
its customers have lent the company
around 1.6 billion dollars
in some ways starbucks is a technology
company
competing favorably with paypal even
some traditional banks are fearful of
what it might do
next why how did starbucks
behind all of our backs become a bank
arguably the first genius idea in
starbucks history
was to carefully craft an experience its
physical locations would be just as much
an attraction as its coffee more than
just a restaurant though
each coffee house was designed to act as
a third place
in our lives something that would
complement both the
rigid formal setting that is the
workplace and our private homes it was
well timed
as it grew during the 90s and early
2000s
the number of shared spaces which served
a communal
social inclusive role were in decline
fewer malls for example were being built
and many sat empty or forgotten
at the same time many people were
becoming self-employed
or had begun working from home creating
the need for a place with good wifi
ample caffeine and air conditioning
tacky as it may sound starbucks was also
supposed to be
friendly in a small town neighborhood
kind of way
encouraging its employees to get to know
regulars
make small talk and personalize each cup
with its customers name
misspelled as they may be besides these
reasons
starbucks grew thanks to its great
branding remarkable consistency
and yes arguably the taste of its coffee
most impressively it expanded very
rapidly
without franchising the company believed
from the very beginning that it needed
to exert
very tight control over every process
and
facet of its presentation it was also
very good at scouting locations so much
so
that there's a so-called frappuccino
effect in real estate
a significant increase in nearby
property prices when a new location
opens according to the ceo of zillow
in the time a normal home has
appreciated by 65 percent
one near a starbucks location will have
appreciated by
96 percent this is likely due in part to
the perceived value of its convenience
but also in large part to starbucks's
ability to find
up-and-coming neighborhoods before the
rest of the market
the very first location opened in
seattle
in 1971. there were 84 locations in 1990
677 in 1995
the first international in japan during
1996
3501 by the turn of the millennium
and 16680 in 2008.
at its peak over seven new stores were
opening
each day around this time however
starbucks began showing signs that it
had grown too big
too fast some in the company attributed
these issues to the wider global
recession
but it was hard to ignore the increasing
competition from mcdonald's
the concern about oversaturation and
rising customer dissatisfaction
this culminated when howard schultz a
board member at the time
wrote a brutally honest internal memo
that was somehow leaked to the press
the email openly questions its focus on
efficiency
and speed over quality and suggests
politely
that the company had lost its magic it
was time for a change
if starbucks was to continue being
starbucks
it needed to do something drastic and
that
it did schultz who wrote the leaked memo
was effectively the founder of modern
starbucks
taking over the brand in 1982 back when
it was just
four little coffee houses in the pacific
northwest
he stepped down in 2000 to devote his
time to international expansion
with a focus on china but in the rocky
times of 2008
schultz was asked to return to the
position of ceo
he inherited the company's worst
three-month performance in its history
and was tasked with guiding it back to
its glory days
after just one month in his new role
schultz made a drastic decision
things had gotten so sloppy he needed to
make
a big gesture to reinvigorate the
company
he decided to close every single store
for one day
at an estimated cost of six million
dollars in lost
profit that day its 135
000 baristas at the time were reminded
of the very basics
how to pour coffee please customers and
pay attention to the details
later that year a similar all hands on
board meeting
was called at the corporate level 10 000
of its partners were flown to new
orleans for an additional 30 million
dollars
where they were updated during a
three-day conference
and then came the really hard part
starbucks closed
600 stores in 2008 followed by 300 more
in 2009 it did on the other hand
continue offering free online college to
every employee
working more than 20 hours a week in
partnership with arizona state
university
among quick serve restaurants jobs at
starbucks are highly coveted
and see lower than average turnover one
of the less high-profile changes
was an increasing focus on technology
this began with the introduction of the
starbucks card
for the uninitiated the way it works now
in 2021
is this instead of paying with cash or
credit card
you can also add money to your starbucks
account
then you can pay with the app on your
phone giving you twice the number of
stars
which let you redeem free drinks while
this may not sound all that
revolutionary
starbucks is the most popular restaurant
rewards
app allowing it to do what others can't
because of its size and customer loyalty
people are not afraid to keep decent
chunks of their money in their starbucks
account
knowing they'll use it eventually 41 of
us
and canadian users pay with their
starbucks card
at the end of 2019 users held a
collective
1.5 billion dollars in balances
to put this in perspective 85 percent of
all u.s banks have less than 1 billion
dollars
in total assets customers will
of course eventually exchange this money
for coffee
but in the meantime unknowingly provide
starbucks
with a 1.5 billion dollar loan at zero
percent
interest that's money starbucks could
simply invest in the market
earning free money from the generosity
of its users
or spend on building more stores
actually it's even better than that
about 10 percent of this money will be
forgotten or lost
and never used known in the industry as
breakage
but here's the thing starbucks is not a
bank
legally speaking with only a few
exceptions
starbucks balance cannot be withdrawn
for cash
only coffee allowing it to bypass
financial regulation
and use deposited money however it likes
it doesn't for example have to keep a
certain amount of cash ready on hand in
case of mass
withdrawals if it wanted to starbucks
has all the ingredients necessary to
build a fully fledged
currency or partner with other brands to
create a widely available mobile payment
system customers already use starbucks
gift cards as the next
best thing to money it's the go-to gift
to someone you don't
know super well but don't want to give
cash
it's sorta liquid not just because it
can be converted to coffee
but because you can be reasonably sure
anyone will have use for it
making it an almost universal
intermediary
all this is very scary to regular old
banks
the ceo of south korea's third largest
financial group
was quoted calling starbucks an
unregulated bank
not a mere coffee company it's anyone's
guess what starbucks will do
next or what its ultimate goals are
in the meantime though no one can say it
hasn't kept up with the times
or managed an incredible comeback
as just about every company slowly
becomes a
technology company there's never been a
better time to learn
computer science brilliant is a great
way to start off 2021 by learning the
right way
there are no grades or homework just
beautiful
interactive lessons laid out almost like
stories
you learn subjects like programming
statistics
probability logic games and much much
more all at your own pace with no
deadlines
and even if you like from your phone use
the link in the description
to sign up for free and start learning
today the first
200 people to use that link will also
get
20 percent off the annual premium
subscription